NARRATOR: Tonight, things get
even nastier in the tank.
You're so full of [bleep]
it doesn't add up.
There's no chance
on God's green Earth
that this deal
could ever possibly close.
Mr. Cuban accused him
of being here for only exposure.
In the tank,
hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes
of getting an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
We've sold over 500 units.
Why isn't it more?
NARRATOR: The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
I think
the idea sucks.
With u-lace,
the possibilities are endless.
NARRATOR: If the sharks
hear a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money.
JOHN:
You're the real deal,
and this
is a real company.
I'm interested.
NARRATOR: And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
Not everybody
is super-aggressive,
full of themselves,
like you.
Do your own deal, Robert.
I made an offer.
Robert, you're trying
to undercut me.
No kidding, bozo.
Yeah, well, you better
put in your mouthpiece,
'cause this is
about to get ugly.
ooh!
NARRATOR:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin o'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu,
with over $6 billion
in retail sales to date.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
Lori Greiner, the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents and
has launched over 300 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in retail sales.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur, tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
First into the tank
is an entrepreneur
with a revolutionary
new bike accessory.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Kent frankovich.
I'm a mechanical engineer
from San Francisco, California,
and co-founder of revolights.
I am seeking $150,000
in exchange
for 10% of my company.
So, traditional bike lights
generally consist of a small,
forward-facing white light
that mounts to your handlebars
and a small,
rear-facing red light
that mounts
to the back of your bike.
Well, we think
this approach is incorrect,
considering an estimated 70%
of nighttime
car-on-bike collisions
can be attributed
to inadequate side visibility.
We want to eliminate
that statistic,
and let me show you how.
Revolights consist
of intelligent rings of LEDs
that mount to your wheels
and synchronize to your speed
to create
a forward-projecting headlight
that stays in the right position
at any speed,
a rear-facing,
functioning brake light,
and a dramatic increase
in your side visibility.
That is so cool.
JOHN: Yeah, very cool.
Really smart.
FRANKOVICH: So, demand has been
overwhelming for our product,
but in order to make this thing
really take off,
we need to get to
a more mainstream price,
lower our cost of goods,
and for that,
I need your help.
Who wants to come up
and check out the lights?
Ooh!
CUBAN:
I'll try your lights.
[ Greiner chuckles ]
CUBAN: By the way,
that's what Daymond wears
when he rides his bike.
huh?
[ laughing ] Okay.
Trust me. Daymond doesn't
ride a bike -- ever.
Of course I do.
All right, you got to
really start going.
Yeah.
Okay.
Kent, how did you come up with
this idea, while he's riding?
So, I originally
had the idea
riding home from my lab
at Stanford in grad school.
Um, I finished up,
and I was going through
a lot of dark patches,
and I was just hitting bumps
and potholes at the last minute,
and I finally said
to myself,
"man, I need
a better headlight."
and so --
but I started thinking,
I didn't want to just go
and buy a more bright headlight.
I wanted to make
a more efficient headlight
by putting the light
where it's needed --
as far forward and close
to the ground as possible.
O'LEARY: Before you finish,
let us -- I want to look at it.
I want to see
how this is facing forward.
Yeah, come on up.
Check it out.
So, the way it works,
there's rings of LEDs.
They attach to your wheel,
so as they go, there's --
at low speeds,
there's an accelerometer
that's figuring out forward
at all times.
O'LEARY:
One size fits all?
Right now, we're just
road bikes and hybrid bikes.
That's our first product.
Can I retrofit it
to an existing bike,
an existing wheel?
yes. yep.
GREINER: Can you
pass that out around to us?
The wheel? Yeah.
Is -- is it something
that you clip onto the wheel?
Um, so --
any wheel?
We have --
right now, we sell a kit
that allows you to install
hardware onto your spokes,
but we also have now
a wheel with the lights
permanently riveted in.
It also looks like
it could be stolen.
So, stolen is actually
a big point,
because that is
one of people's main concerns
with bike lights currently.
We manufacture them
to be solid rings,
so when you lock up
your wheels,
you're actually locking up
your lights.
I'm assuming
you have a patent for it.
We now have
two granted utility patents.
Okay,
have you considered
licensing it to one of the two
giant bike manufacturers?
Absolutely.
We wanted to get
to a point
where we were proving
the market,
and we started building them
into wheels,
and we're using that
as an example.
Great strategy.
What are your sales
so far?
So, we haven't been selling
for more than 12 months,
and in those 12 months,
we have sold
$600,000 worth of our product --
online,
almost exclusively.
oh!
What does it cost to make?
How much do you sell it for?
So, currently, we are selling
each individual set,
front or back, for $139.
The full set,
you can buy for $229.
You made $600,000
in what period of time?
So, that's in about
10 months of sales.
How much of that
is profit?
So, we have not become
profitable yet.
Okay.
So, we --
what does it cost you
to make it?
The next order we're gonna place
is $100, about.
It costs you $100,
and you sell it for $229.
Costs us $100.
For a set or one?
Yes, that's for a set.
JOHN: And why
do you not make profit?
Is it because of
the margin, or --
because he's investing
and growing and doing r&d, yeah.
Or is it because
you're putting money back in?
That's what I was
gonna ask.
Yeah.
It's money back in.
I mean, we don't --
I've seen strips
that you can put around
mm-hmm. yes.
That just are for color
and for fun,
but this is much stronger,
so do you have --
costs 10 times more,
though.
Oh, yeah. I mean,
those cost, like, 20 bucks.
Yeah.
But do you have any competition
in this space
for doing something
that's a very bright light
that's screaming, "a bike
is right here. watch out."
so, there is nothing
that provides the visibility
patch that we do.
My background
is mechanical engineering.
I was actually
at the jet-propulsion lab,
which is NASA's
unmanned-space-flight wing.
I was on the Mars
science lab mission.
Wow, we've never
had somebody come in here
and pitch
that worked at NASA.
[ chuckles ]
You're a real
rocket scientist.
Rocket engineer.
It's a big difference.
Yeah.
So, I'm gonna
get the party started here.
[ laughing ] Okay.
$300,000 for 30%.
[ sighs ]
Just think about it
for a second.
I'll make you an offer
that's probably more attractive.
Um, I don't want
any of your equity.
I know where this is going,
and remember,
perpetuity is
the new broke, so --
right.
No, but i-i may craft it
in a different way.
I would give you the $150,000 --
exactly what you asked for --
and I'd take a 7% royalty
till I get my $150,000 back,
and then I'd drop it down
to 1% in perpetuity.
It's like the wheel.
It always spins and ends up
in the same spot.
Exactly.
You keep your equity,
'cause t-t-the truth is,
the equity in this company could
be very, very valuable one day.
Well, first off, thank you
very much, both of you,
for making an offer.
Um, Kevin,
to speak to your point
real quick on the royalty --
we're at an early stage
in our company,
and that cash flow out
can stifle our growth.
Bang. Best answer
to his royalty thing.
Would you rather --
would you rather I lent you
the money, i-i was a lender?
Right now, what we want
is an equity investment.
Kent,
I'll make you an offer.
Okay.
Incredibly clever
and smart idea,
thank you.
And you must be Croatian,
with a name like frankovich.
[ Greiner laughs ]
Yep. I am.
Did you come over in
a boat with a little
rice and rats in it?
Yeah, absolutely.
[ laughs ]
so, you're asking
for $150,000 for 10%?
Correct.
I'll give you $300,000
for 10%.
Oh! Wait a minute.
GREINER: Whoo!
I think your value
is actually too low.
I do think
you undervalued it.
Robert, you're trying
to undercut me.
No kidding, bozo.
Yeah, well, you better
put in your mouthpiece,
'cause this is
about to get ugly.
NARRATOR: Kent has three offers
on the table,
but Robert
has generously offered
double the money
that Kent was seeking.
So, you're asking
for $150,000 for 10%.
Correct.
I'll give you $300,000
for 10%.
Oh! Wait a minute.
GREINER: Whoo!
I think your value
is actually too low.
Robert, you're trying
to undercut me.
No kidding, bozo.
Yeah, well, you better
put in your mouthpiece,
'cause this is
about to get ugly.
GREINER: Wow.
That is an incredibly generous
offer, Robert.
I have to put
the ego aside,
and I don't want
to get into a bidding war.
I'm gonna have to say
Robert did give you
a very...generous offer.
I'll step out.
Thank you again
for the offer, Daymond.
I'm still here.
[ laughter ]
Robert, you have
an incredible offer.
I would like to see
if any of the sharks
who are still in
would like to make an offer,
as well, before I decide.
Such a nice way
to say no.
Robert's right. It's worth
a lot more. And you know that.
You have your background
and your experience
and $600,000 in sales.
People are probably
throwing money at you.
You don't come in and ask
for a $1.5 million valuation.
Unless you're screwing with us,
it makes no sense whatsoever.
I think there's no chance
on God's green Earth
that this deal
could ever possibly close,
because you'd be an idiot
among your friends
to value this company at
$1.5 million or even $3 million.
It doesn't add up.
Did you just insult him?
Yes!
Because
he's insulting us.
Mark Cuban just crapped on you.
What do you say?
So, here's the response.
I think that we have absolutely
been looking to find investment.
The fact is,
coming and talking to you guys
and the connections
that you have
and the networks
and the experience
that you have --
you are
so full of [bleep]
excuse my French.
Connections is
the least of your worries.
And I'm just --
I'm being brutally honest.
Robert offered you
twice...
Of what you asked for.
...What you were asking for
at the same valuation.
You didn't even put up
a little bit of a smile.
So, what are you doing,
Mark?
I'm out.
Wow.
I feel like
Mark has brought up something
GREINER: Kent.
that I really
need to defend.
One second.
Lori's gonna --
well, wait a second.
Well, then, do it,
Kent. Do it.
GREINER: Well, you go ahead.
Answer it. Answer it, answer it.
Okay, so --
you have the guts.
Don't let people
talk down to you like that.
You were so smart,
capital was not a problem.
You were smart enough
to come on here,
push down the valuation
'cause that opens that door...
At the very least, you're
suspicious of his motivations?
Yes.
The first -- the first thing
that you're bringing up
is that capital's not a problem,
which is not accurate.
I've been working
for a year and a half,
and so has all the other people
in our office,
without being paid,
so, no,
capital is actually an issue.
And, frankly,
the way I see this show
is we are able to partner
with somebody
who has amazing connections,
who has the ability to get us
to the point where we need to be
to start
really moving product.
So, why won't you
just say yes to Robert?
$300,000 for 10%.
Bam -- you got the capital,
you got connections.
Yes.
Say yes!
Because
he's a nice guy.
You know, not everybody
is super-aggressive,
full of themselves,
like you.
How do you feel,
making a great offer,
and he's not answering you
right now?
You know what?
You might be right.
Kent might never close
with me,
but I'm not getting that vibe
from the guy.
Okay.
You're also not getting
an answer from him.
Make your own deal.
He knows that we're out
over here.
Do your own deal, Robert.
I made an offer.
Kevin, I greatly appreciate
your offer,
but I'm gonna have to say,
I need to go with Robert.
O'LEARY: Wow.
GREINER:
Congratulations.
Congratulations, Kent.
You'd better not
be wasting my time, man.
[ laughing ]
I'm -- I'm absolutely
not wasting your time.
Thank you very much.
JOHN: Good luck, guys.
T-thank you.
So, basically,
what Mr. Cuban accused him of
was being here
for only exposure.
I offered the guy an offer.
He didn't say no to me.
What he said was,
in a nice way,
"I'd like to hear
what other people say."
if I'm standing right there
and I say,
"I want $150,000 for 10%,"
and then somebody,
while I'm standing there,
says, "I'll give you
$300,000 for 10%,"
the normal response is...
[ gasps ] "wow!"
he didn't flinch!
Mark, you know what?
You're a pushy guy,
and you pushed the guy,
and you rattled him.
I just sat back
and listened.
You know what, Mark?
I only have the faith of the
people that come in here --
no, look,
we'll find out.
But I'm not gonna be
rude to people when
they come out here.
That's why
they play the games.
We'll see.
NARRATOR:
Last season, Mary Beth lugo
made a deal with Mark Cuban
for her product, kazam...
Whoa.
...A pedal-less
training bike for toddlers.
Do we have a deal?
We have a deal.
Amen.
O'LEARY: All right!
I'm proud of you.
[ laughs ]
Thank you.
NARRATOR:
Let's see how she's doing now.
LUGO:
Business has been phenomenal.
Since "shark tank,"
we've done $1 million in sales.
Over the next 12 months,
we're projecting $2 million
in sales.
Mark's team has helped us land
the biggest deal to date --
SkyMall.
Not only are we
in 5 million printed copies,
but also online
and with viewership,
up to 160 million passengers.
Mark and his team have helped us
incorporate kazam
into our very first
preschool program,
and I just had to come out
to Dallas to check it out.
Who's ever been
on a bike before?
Me!
Yeah?
Have you guys ever ridden
a bike with no pedals?
No!
Well, come on!
Let's do it!
When I walk into a classroom
and see the children using kazam
and having fun,
it's just such a great feeling.
I think Harrison won.
Kazam is a fun way to get kids
active at an early age,
build their self-esteem,
and establish their balance.
That was cool.
Bringing an idea to life,
building a brand name,
and being recognized
as a quality product
is all I've ever wanted,
and thanks to "shark tank,"
that's all come true.
ALL: We love kazam!
I'm Lisa.
And I'm Ivan.
And we're from
Los Angeles, California.
[ squeals ]
We have two children.
Our son, Elijah, is 5,
and our daughter, Vivian, is 2.
Wow. That looks
kind of cool.
Our product was inspired
by our kids.
Like most parents,
we want to keep them safe.
We want to know where they are,
what they're doing,
and that they're not
getting into something
that they shouldn't.
IVAN:
When Elijah was first born,
Lisa and I were both so busy,
so her mom was a huge help
and would watch Elijah,
and he's
an active little guy.
He would be crawling around,
getting bruises and scrapes.
My mom suggested
that I design something
that gave him
a little extra protection
but also helped her
keep an ear out
for where he was
and what he was doing.
Well,
after I make the lunches,
then I'll get started
on your breakfast.
I now work on the business
full time
while staying at home
to take care of our kids.
Elijah, let's go!
Let's go!
Being a stay-at-home mom
and running and starting
a business is not easy.
Coffee?
Let's go.
It's a lot
of hard work,
but I wouldn't want
to be doing anything else.
That's how much we're gonna
have to pay for everything.
Oh, whoa.
We've risked
our family's financial security
to develop
this product.
For our latest production run,
I had to, essentially,
Max out our credit cards
to see it through.
We need the sharks
in a big way.
There's nothing like our product
on the market,
and we want to be first
to market and hit it big.
Hi. I'm Lisa.
And I'm her husband,
Ivan.
And we created
squeeky knees.
We're asking for $80,000
in exchange for a 20% equity
in our company.
There's nothing
more important to parents
than keeping their kids
safe,
and our product
does just that.
Squeeky knees are
soft, squeaky pants
for the baby
on the go.
I'm a stay-at-home mom
of two young children,
and our kids
do not stop.
When our son began crawling,
I noticed
that his knees would become
bruised and scuffed.
To top it off,
I couldn't leave the room
without him
getting into something.
I needed a product that
not only protected his knees,
but integrated
a fun sound
so I could keep an ear out
for where he was.
There was clearly a problem,
and now we have a solution --
squeeky knees.
[ squeaking ]
[ baby coos ]
[ laughs ]
[ squeaking ]
Oh, my goodness.
Squeeky knees are
infant and toddler legwear
that have
built-in knee pads
and a squeaker device that makes
a fun and entertaining sound
when babies crawl.
Their knees stay protected,
and kids love wearing them.
EVANS: So, sharks,
who wants to make some noise
in the baby industry with us?
I'm gonna pass out
some product.
[ laughing ]
All right.
So, you took a doggie toy and
you put it in knees for kids?
[ chuckles ]
That's not exactly it.
But close enough, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Doesn't it get
irritating?
I can completely understand
where you might think that,
but, like, I come home
from a long, hard day at work,
and when I see my son and
my daughter crawling in those,
[ all squeaking ]
making those noises,
it's, like, an endearing sound.
It's -- I love it.
I love that sound.
Yeah, 'cause
you weren't home all day.
Your wife is going,
"oh, my God!
If I hear that squeak
one more time..."
[ squeaking ]
that's the sound of money
to me.
[ squeaking ]
Well, how much money
have you made?
How many
have you sold?
We've sold
over 500 units.
We've -- we've made t-- over t--
a little over $10,000 in sales.
And how long
have you been in business?
We've been in business
for three years.
Wow. You just hit a buzz saw.
Three years, $10,000?
But the first year was dedicated
to intellectual property.
We wanted
to patent this.
JOHN: So, now
tell me where you're at
and, uh,
why was it so small,
and why do you think
it's going to scale big?
I'm a stay-at-home mom.
We're on one income only.
You know, I do my best.
If we don't have the funds
to do a production run,
then I'm on social media,
I'm on Facebook,
I'm putting them on my daughter
at the park, I'm talking to --
Lisa, I get that,
but is there a possibility --
and how many are you selling
off your daughter in the park?
For example, when you put
your daughter out in the park,
yeah.
how many people say,
"oh, my gosh. I love that.
I want to buy it"?
Most people do.
I hand them a card,
I say, "visit our website,"
and they do,
and people love them.
Apparently not!
Nobody's buying them.
If people loved them,
do you think
your sales would be higher?
You know what? I do.
But because we can't
market it in a big way --
we don't have
any advertising.
yeah, we've done
literally no marketing.
Wait a second. I have a question
I want to get answered.
We have a website.
Is there a possibility --
people couldn't really
find us, so...
Is there a possibility,
as you're explaining
why you have no sales,
is there a possibility
that nobody wants squeeky knees?
Well, you know what?
There's a possibility
for a lot of things.
Not right now.
No, no, wait a second.
Okay.
I really believe
I may be right.
I think the idea sucks.
And that's why
there's no sales.
Okay.
Is that a possibility,
maybe?
Let me answer this.
Anything is possible.
Don't smile. I'm giving you
a serious accusation.
Through our website,
like I mentioned,
we have limited marketing.
A buyer reached out to us
from zulily,
one of the biggest
targeted flash sites.
They said, "I love your product.
Let's do a deal."
they put us
on their flash site.
We sold through
50% of our product.
They said, "we love it."
how much was it,
though?
It was like 50 pieces.
Guys.
This hurts.
So, you guys, normally,
if something's really great,
people are lining up
to buy it.
They don't just say,
"oh, yay. Give me your card."
maybe this isn't
the right idea.
I'm out.
[ groans ]
Okay, well,
thank you, Lori.
Thank you.
We appreciate it.
One thing --
i-i want to say this.
We haven't really
gotten it out there.
We're at the point
right now,
this is like the jump-off point,
you get in here now --
right over the cliff,
baby.
you're gonna be able to make
a lot of money.
You're going right down.
You could make a lot of money
on this, worldwide.
We have to think about
middle America, you know?
In some places --
CUBAN:
I like the idea, guys,
but there's a difference
between a product and a company.
JOHN: Absolutely.
You guys are a product.
Right.
But you're a mom and a dad
that has a good idea
and is looking
to turn it into a company.
You're not there yet.
You always have to
run your business
like there's
someone else out there
working 24 hours a day
to kick your butt.
But you're at work,
and you're picking up the kids.
But you know what?
I resent that.
I'm not saying
you can't make it work.
Full-time moms
don't get enough respect
in our culture right now.
that's not the issue.
Wait, wait, wait.
But that's not the issue.
That's not the issue.
The issue is,
you're competing.
Right, because I'm a mom
and I have to pick up my kids,
that I can't
also run a business?
That's not what I said.
What I said was, you're
competing with other people
that don't have
the same limitations.
So it's a limit
to be a mother?
That's nonsense.
You're -- you're making excuses.
The reality is, there aren't
enough hours in the day.
There's somebody
who's working full time.
Yeah, absolutely.
They're not cutting
half the day off, right?
They're not going
to another job.
To think that
that person working full time
doesn't have an advantage
is lying to yourself.
I'm out.
Look, I have no problem
with the fact that you're a mom
and you're doing it part time
and Ivan's doing it part time.
I just think
it's a little too soon.
I'm out.
Thank you.
All right,
thank you, Robert.
O'LEARY:
The market has spoken,
and it's basically telling you
people hate this product.
I hate it, too.
If you keep investing in it,
you're killing money.
You don't want to do that
to money.
This is a bad idea,
and it's got to go away.
And you were
my favorite.
I'm telling you the truth!
This sucks!
I'm out.
Whew!
Is he still your favorite?
Not anymore.
[ laughs ]
Good for you.
[ laughter ]
Daymond, you're the only one
left in here.
I was -- I --
make some sense of it.
O'LEARY:
What are you gonna do, D.J.?
JOHN:
So, I was rooting for you.
That's why I was
trying to set up, you know,
why it took three years.
It could have been
2 1/2 years in development.
But as everyone spoke,
you not only, you know,
didn't want to take any advice,
but you objected, to the point
where you seem very --
I'm all ears.
I'm sorry. I --
I think we were open.
Listen.
Okay.
When I was on the fence
of investing,
I just felt that
we would spend more time arguing
than anything else.
that is just --
oh, man,
not -- not so, no so.
That's not gonna happen,
Daymond.
You actually
considered investing?
That is just my feeling.
That's not gonna happen.
How can we
convince you otherwise?
Because we're --
we're a dynamic team.
Because you're not
letting me speak now, either.
Okay.
I'm out.
Oh, Daymond.
So, can we call you
when we have some sales?
Come back to the tent
in a couple years
good luck, you guys.
if you get there.
Many have proven us wrong.
Thank you.
[ squeaking ]
That's the sound of money.
Thank you.
Oh, I hated that product.
Can you imagine that
every two seconds?
GREINER:
Oh, my God. No, I can't.
I hated that product.
I can't imagine it.
This would make me crazy.
We tried. Yeah.
I'm a stay-at-home mom.
I'm trying to start a company.
[ voice breaking ]
I feel like I can do this,
And if, you know,
a couple of men
who have a ton of money
don't see it,
then they don't see --
they don't have the vision.
But I'm not gonna
let them stop me.
NARRATOR:
Next up is an entrepreneur
who believes he has an essential
for every well-dressed man.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Mike Quinn, and I'm
the creator of the buffer bit.
I am seeking $75,000
for 25% of the business.
You know, before the buffer bit,
I would spend 15, 20 minutes
polishing my shoes
with a shoeshine kit.
The problem is, it's a hassle.
You have somebody do it for you,
and it's expensive.
It's time to change shoe care,
and the buffer bit
is a game-changing product.
All you need is the buffer bit
and any cordless drill
[ chuckles ]
for a fast, world-class
shoeshine.
[ whirring ]
But the buffer bit is much more
than a shoe-care product.
There's more?
There's more.
Simply attach
the natural pad,
and the buffer bit
transforms
into a powerful
automotive-detailing product.
So, sharks, who wants
to redefine their shine?
[ laughter ]
O'LEARY: Wow.
So, Mike,
all you've done
is you've made a drill bit
with fur on it...
[ chuckles ]
...To replace
an electric polisher.
Yes.
Mike, at the airport,
I got my shoes shined,
and the guy came out with a --
[ imitating drill ]
and he was doing my shoes
with the same thing.
This already exists,
doesn't it?
Well, it -- it exists --
an electric shoe polisher,
and that was actually
the concept of the --
of the invention.
Electric polisher's
about $14.95.
Your bit is how much?
A-a shoe polisher is
much more than $14.95.
How much are they?
$50 to $100.
CUBAN:
And what do you sell these for?
$19.99.
And what does it cost you
to make them?
Right now, it costs me $9
to make each one.
The idea of taking
a power tool to -- to my shoes,
do you think
guys are gonna do that?
I think guys are gonna
look for an excuse
to use
their cordless drill.
[ laughter ]
So true.
I used to work
in a menswear store.
They always say
you can tell a lot about a guy
by his watch
and if his shoes are shined.
Mike, could I try it?
Sure. Yeah, absolutely.
You want to shine
my shoes, Mark?
You can't afford me,
Robert.
And, by the way,
I don't ever wear a watch,
because some of us
don't have to.
GREINER AND JOHN: Ooooh!
Uh, w-what is --
[ mockingly ] oooh!
JOHN:
3:00 in the schoolyard!
Oh, you want to do it here?
Okay, great. Yeah.
[ laughter ]
There you go.
[ whirring ]
Does it always have
that pungent smell like dead --
it doesn't smell.
Oh, that's 'cause
your shoe's off.
GREINER:
That's Mark's foot.
[ laughter ]
[ whirring stops ]
[ laughs ]
[ whirring ]
Does it work on that?
[ laughter ]
CUBAN: This actually
works pretty well.
Yeah. Yeah, no.
It sure does.
All right,
well, all right.
We get it.
Do you have sales,
Mike?
Well, I just started.
We're nine months into it.
Sales of, um, $30,000.
Mike, is there anything
proprietary about this?
Yeah. Well, we have
a provisional patent granted.
Have you tried selling it
in a hardware store?
I did. Actually, I took it
to two hardware mass retailers.
I brought it in there
just as a guy off the street.
They liked it a lot.
And what happened?
Well, they didn't like
the fact
that I was working out of
my basement on this project.
Mike, I think you've got
a cool product. I really do.
I think you can do
a lot of unique things.
But honestly,
you're not a company yet.
There's no structure to you
at all.
And I don't think
there's enough upside there
where I can get a return
as an investor,
and so, for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you.
GREINER: For me,
I don't know enough
about how many men
polish their shoes.
It seems it's a little bit
of a dying breed
because people are going
more and more casual.
So I'm out.
Thank you.
Mike, I just don't see
the application.
I'm out.
Thank you.
O'LEARY: Mike,
I'll tell you a little story.
I'm a member of a group called
the chevaliers du tastevin.
It's a secret society
of burgundy drinkers.
[ laughter ]
And every 90 days, somewhere
in the world, we gather,
And we drink wines
as old as 1902.
But you can't do it unless
you're wearing your tastevin,
which is a tasting cup
made of pure silver.
If the cup is dirty,
you're rejected
from the meeting,
no matter where it's held.
Could be Paris,
could be Rome.
You can't get in.
I can't believe
I'm hearing this.
I keep telling my wife,
"you got to polish my tastevin."
she says,
"polish your own tastevin."
[ laughter ]
I actually think I could
polish my tastevin with this.
But, having said all that,
I'm a buyer of it,
but as an investor,
I'm out.
Thank you.
[ laughing ]
What the hell is a tastevin?
HERJAVEC: Mike, I'm not
a member of a secret society.
I don't even know
what a tastevin is.
I do know
Kevin is full of crap.
[ laughter ]
You will not be invited
to the next meeting.
I know Mark made fun
of the fact he doesn't
have to wear a watch,
but, you know, I think no matter
how successful you get,
it's always the little things
that count.
Showing up on time,
having a clean pair of shoes --
goes a long way.
To be successful, you got to
look successful in most things.
Until you become Mr. Cuban.
Then you can look like a slob.
Hey, I've always been a slob.
It's worked.
But I respect someone with
a good-looking pair of shoes.
Just -- I don't know
at this point
whether you've developed
the market or not,
and I wouldn't
buy this product.
I'm out.
All right. Thank you.
Good luck.
And that's
a clean pair of shoes.
All right, thank you.
[ whirring ]
CUBAN: How do you
spell "testavant"?
O'LEARY: Tastevin.
Yeah, what was that?
Chevaliers du tastevin.
Google it right now.
So, you get kicked out
of your little club
if your cup is dirty?
Spell --
yes, it's -- it's
the very famous silver cup
you wear
around your neck.
i-i'm just curious.
Obviously,
you're not a member.
"ever since its creation
in 1934, the confrrie"...
It's real?
Imagine 20 Kevin o'learys
with the little cups
around their necks.
No, no, it's 80.
It's 80.
"the order has some 12,000
knights of chevaliers
worldwide."
you said there was 80.
In our chapter.
[ laughter ]
NARRATOR:
Next into the tank
is a product to make sneakers
more functional and fashionable.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Tim talley.
I'm from Rochester, New York.
My company is u-lace,
and I'm seeking $200,000
in return for 25% of my company.
If you have kids,
you probably already know this,
but the average American kid
owns over 10 pairs of sneakers.
But why do they need
so many pairs of sneakers?
Well, it's really quite simple.
They need the variety to express
their own sense of style
and to hook up with other things
in their wardrobe.
But what if
those same pairs of sneakers
could quickly, easily,
and inexpensively
be customized
again and again and again,
turning each
of those pairs of sneakers
into millions
of pairs of sneakers?
Well, sharks, I'm here today
with some awesome news.
My product, u-lace
sneaker customizing laces,
makes all of this possible
and more.
U-laces are
elastic shoelace inserts
that enable users to lace
multiple colors and patterns
into their sneakers.
U-laces pop in and out
with ease,
which means you can swap colors
or change patterns
as often as you like.
What's more,
once laced with u-lace,
sneakers instantly become
slip-ons
that never need to be tied.
So you get to say hello
to customization,
hello to slip-ons,
and bye-bye
to bows that come untied.
U-lace truly puts the "kick"
back into kicks.
Sharks, I have a pair of
sneakers for each of you today.
Oh, cool.
All right! This is the way
to start off a pitch.
[ laughter ]
Robert, I believe these are
your home-city colors.
Thank you.
Lori, these are
cool fashion metallics.
I like them.
Kevin, these are
your country colors.
O'LEARY: Yeah.
Daymond,
your high-school colors.
Nice!
And yes, Mark, these are
the mavericks' colors.
Yes, sir.
School colors, team colors,
fashion colors, country colors,
whatever colors -- with u-lace,
the possibilities are endless.
Sharks, we have
an award-winning product,
we have the market's attention,
and we have global distribution.
What we really need now is
a really cool partner like you.
So, you know what they say --
"if the shoe fits, invest."
that's interesting.
so, it works
by just simply
putting one in one side
like this,
and then just going right
through underneath the top.
absolutely.
So, there's just
this little hook piece.
Just a little tab.
I take out the existing lace,
and I replace it with yours?
You take out the existing lace
and replace it with ours.
Show us the packaging.
Give us a few packages
to look at.
So, Tim, how do I tighten it
once it's in?
The cool thing about it is
that you can fine-tune the fit
um, by -- by changing
the design pattern.
So, there are design patterns
that are very loose.
We have skateboard kids that
like to have a very loose fit.
Oh, so you can stretch
it across two holes
for extra tightness?
You get to choose any two
eyelet holes on the shoe
right. Oh, I see.
Per -- p-per u-lace.
How much?
We sell that pack
for $3.49.
And what does it cost you
to make it?
35 cents.
Yes!
[ Greiner laughs ]
nice.
Walk us through
your distribution strategy.
Well, we have
a global distribution network.
Basically,
they pay for everything.
They order through us.
We -- we make about a 50%
profit margin just on that.
And you've been in business
how many years?
We started shipping this product
in 2009, and then we've been --
what will you do this year
in sales?
This year, through August,
we're at $193,000.
$193,000?
Yes.
Tim,
why isn't it more?
Yeah.
You've got distribution
in place.
After four years,
why isn't it more?
I'll tell you why it isn't more.
We came out in 2009.
We were named
number-one hot new product
in Japan in 2010,
and then it just took off.
So we did about $300,000.
But then what happened was
the earthquake and tsunami came
and buried
our Japanese distributor.
Why do the Japanese love it
and the Americans don't?
I invented the product
in Japan.
I was actually trendspotting
in Japan
when I came up with the idea.
I left my job,
and I went to Japan,
specifically going
to find an idea.
What was your job?
I ran the biggest business
for new era cap company.
Right. For new era.
So that's why you were
trendspotting, 'cause that's --
that's not a word
that a normal person uses
unless they're
in the fashion industry.
So, Tim, my little risk antenna
just went up
because trendspotting
is meaning
that a trend comes,
peaks, goes.
No, that's a fad.
[ laughter ]
Well...
No, that's a fad.
You got him!
Ba-bam!
GREINER: Well said.
That's a fad. A trend --
a trend can last for
many, many, many years.
Yeah,
but poo-poo happens,
and all of a sudden,
it slowed down,
but it hasn't taken off
stateside yet.
But the pricing wasn't
necessarily right,
and the packaging.
We were putting more
product in the package than,
you know, enough product.
Like, there were 16 segments
in the package, so --
CUBAN: Okay. and you were
selling that for how much?
$7.99.
And you're saying
that was too high a price
because you had
too much product in there.
Absolutely.
How much is it now?
Or maybe people didn't want
that many all at once.
That's right.
So, what we saw as soon
as we reconfigured this product
was we saw our sales going up
to about six to eight packs
per order.
It made it
kind of a no-brainer.
And we're gonna do $400,000
this year.
Are you not selling
in America?
We're not selling in America
beyond our own online
and a couple
big online sneaker retailers.
Why is that, Tim?
I think because we didn't have
the product configuration right,
and I really wanted
to fine-tune and test this.
I thought,
"we got one chance here."
the sneaker business
is a $60 billion business.
Don't start
doing that, man.
No, no, no. I'm just saying
it's a big business.
This should be sitting
at the register
at every large retailer
of sneakers.
JOHN: How many competitors
are out there?
There's a couple
other products out
that are made out of,
like, silicone or rubber.
Is nobody doing this
where you have
that little piece on the end?
Absolutely not, because
we have -- we have a patent.
This is not that easy to do,
by the way.
Um,
it's actually pretty easy
once you get used to kind of
pulling them in and out.
Yeah,
once you got it in --
you're right,
the first time is hard.
What if I wanted
to play a pickup game?
Can it hold up, you know,
so I can play in these?
You know,
I can play in these.
O'LEARY:
I rarely do this,
but I'm gonna ask Daymond
for some advice.
Yes, you should bathe more
often, 'cause I sit next to you.
[ laughter ]
So, bottom line is what?
How long is this
gonna stay trendy?
It could be forever.
You think that?
This could be
a long player.
I'm interested.
No, you know what?
Matter of fact, I don't think
this is gonna last much longer.
[ laughter ]
Tim, what's the projection
for u-lace?
We believe we can do
almost $2 million next year.
What?!
I believe so.
It's a big ramp,
my friend.
Tell me -- tell me how --
tell me what the game plan --
we basically want to go
back to those guys,
to -- to the big retailers
that are very interested,
and maybe not t--
try to take off a big a bite
as they wanted us to take off.
But, Tim,
the key to the strategy
is getting
a couple large retailers.
That's the only way
you're gonna get to $2 million.
Absolutely.
I'm gonna make this easy,
because, you know, I like you.
I think you're a hero.
I think the idea --
he's not a zero?
He's not a zero.
Well, that's good.
That's good news.
My mom will be happy
to hear that.
He's a hero.
But one of the problems
I have with this --
I don't find it
very comfortable,
because I'm feeling
these little pieces underneath
hitting
the top of my foot.
We -- we recommend that you wear
a shoe with a padded tongue.
It is a --
it is a fashion product.
Most kids don't care,
though, right?
The kids that are
doing this, like --
kids don't.
I mean,
they're either not --
their -- their shoelaces
are completely undone,
and they're trying
not to trip over them, right?
Yeah. I just feel that this is
not probably the right --
so, before you --
before you totally drop out,
just -- I want to tell you
a little bit more about me.
Um, you know,
when I was in college,
chairman of the engineering
department called me in
and said,
"Tim, you're outclassed.
"you're never gonna get
an engineering degree.
"you don't have to an engineer.
You can be an electrician.
You know, why don't you
drop out of school, save
your parents some money --"
this is your prof
trash-talking?
this is not
a good professor.
"join the army
and learn a trade."
and what I did was I got rid
of stuff that didn't matter.
I stopped running track
'cause I wasn't gonna make money
running track.
And three years later,
when he passed me my diploma,
he said to me -- he said,
"Tim, I'm sorry
I didn't believe in you
as much
as you believed in yourself."
I think this will do
extremely well.
I just don't think, for me,
um, this is the right product.
I'm out.
Look, Tim,
I love that story.
I think if so many other people
just learn from that --
get rid of the stuff
that doesn't matter in your life
and focus on the stuff
that does, right?
Well --
laser-like focus,
my friend.
I got rid
of my apartment.
I live in a rented room
in a friend's house.
I used to drive
a drop-top Porsche.
I mean, I was
pretty well compensated.
I got rid of my car.
I got lean
because I believe in this
and I know what it can be.
I just need
the right partners.
So, you've kept me in
this entire time
simply because of you.
What I think you need
is you need
somebody with the experience
that's gonna help you.
And look --
there are sharks here
that have better experience
in this area than I do.
I'm out.
Understood.
Daymond.
Fashion.
I'm a little -- yeah, I'm-a get
a little nervous, 'cause --
GREINER: Yeah. Daymond,
this is right up your alley.
Maybe he's being quiet
'cause he doesn't like it.
'cause he's taking it all in.
I'm -- I'm just thinking,
you know?
GREINER:
He's processing.
Okay.
I'm going to...
NARRATOR:
Two sharks are out.
Tim has three more chances
to make a deal.
HERJAVEC:
Daymond. Fashion guru.
I'm a little -- yeah, I'm-a get
a little nervous, 'cause --
yeah. Daymond,
this is right up your alley.
Okay.
I'm going to...
T-the real challenge
I have is
I'm a partner in a company
called snkrbst,
and I just --
I'm a partner,
and we just bought the --
the old shoe company etonic,
all right?
so you're conflicted?
So, I'm sitting here,
thinking,
do I dump the guys
I just acquired or not?
But it, ethically,
would be wrong, and so I --
when has that ever
stopped you before?
[ laughter ]
It's a conflict...
So, regretfully,
I'm out.
I appreciate that.
You know, I understand.
You know, business is --
you know, you want --
I want partners that would
speak up and say that, you know?
And, you know,
that's how we are.
We're -- we're straightforward
with everybody.
That's how I like to run
my business. I don't...
Tim, you got two guys left.
You got Mark, and you got Kevin.
What can I say to you guys
that you haven't heard that --
that would tip this for you?
That's up for you
to decide.
I'm not a guy
that's gonna quit on you.
I'm a guy
that's gonna, you know,
work my fingers to the bone.
This is how I do.
I GET UP AT 3:00
in the morning.
I'm on the phone with
my distributors over in Europe.
I'm on the phone with Asia.
My job here
is not to fight for you,
but they wanted to know
my opinion.
You're the real deal.
You're the real deal,
and this is a real company,
and that's why
I was conflicted.
So you don't have to
speak for yourself.
I'm gonna tell both of them --
this guy's the real deal.
Wow. That's quite
an endorsement.
I appreciate that.
That's quite an endorsement,
Daymond.
I'm just --
but you know
what I say --
never take advice
from someone
who doesn't have to live
with the consequences.
That is true.
[ laughs ]
He's not putting up
any money.
Um, I don't know what
this company's worth right now.
I like it, but I don't know
what it's worth.
Make an offer.
All right, I'll give you
$200,000 for 50%.
First of all,
i-i appreciate
the fact that there is an offer
on the table.
Mm-hmm.
Um...
I really don't know
what it's worth.
It's -- it's a shot
with you rebirthing an idea
that was proven
in a foreign market.
That's the way
I look at it.
Mark?
HERJAVEC:
$200,000, 50%,
and you got Mark over there
really quiet.
I want to hear
what you say to him.
I'm --
I'm processing it as --
it shouldn't be
a process, right?
You already know
the answer.
I-i think it's a bit rich.
Well, come back
with something.
Counter.
I would be willing
to go up to...35%.
I'll do that deal.
Want to do that deal?
Let's do it.
[ Greiner laughs ]
See, I like when I let him
negotiate for me. [ laughs ]
Congrats, Mark.
All right.
Thank you, baby.
Congratulations.
I really like it.
The first thing we'll do
is we'll get it as a mass
premium and as a giveaway.
I'll give them to all
the guys to start
wearing it, handing out.
We'll put them in the mav shop,
and we'll get that rolling.
TALLEY:
Awesome. Thank you.
Great job, Tim.
GREINER: Great job.
You did great.
Thank you, guys.
A deal with Mark
is totally amazing.
He's connected to sports,
he's connected to licensing,
so these are things
that could make our brand huge,
so it's just --
just an awesome feeling.
You didn't like it,
eh?
I loved it.
It's a conflict.
I own a company
like this.
Mark, good one.
Ba-bam!